[Applause]
happy glorious tuesday everyone boy
things are going great around here it's
day two of our amazing halloween
extravaganza so before we get to the
news the next episode of our favorite
sitcom awaits
[Music]
tonight's episode inside the writer's
doom
so i was thinking the show's just not as
funny as it used to be we could use more
laughs anyone else agree
uh
i think the show is as funny as it's
ever been if anything there's too many
laughs
all right free fruit
hey uh fox and friends called apparently
someone murdered brian kilnead and hung
his body upside down in ainslie
earhart's office they want you to fill
in for him
[Music]
applauding death
i always love a happy ending
so have you noticed how great things are
going in america another massive caravan
coming our way surging past mexican
forces and surging past mexico in
general you know i feel bad for mexico
imagine thousands of people apparently
escaping a mortal hell in total
desperation and they enter your country
and say
no thanks we'll keep going
mexico must feel like everyone's first
[Laughter]
wife it is rude
it's like asking the major d of a
restaurant directions to another
restaurant
it's like it's like going up to the
hostess at applebee's and saying excuse
me do you know a place nearby that
offers mainstream american dishes served
in a casual dining atmosphere that
offers pasta burgers and delicious
riblet appetizers and no not you
that's mexico everyone walking right on
through like it's the hosiery department
at macy's
you always had to go through there to
get to some place good
it's more demoralizing than not getting
a rose on the bachelor just ask kat
but that's not the only problem we don't
just have inflation but apparently
hyperinflation i asked larry kudlow what
hyperinflation was and he said greg it's
inflation but hyper
[Laughter]
then he punched me in the face
because that's how he rolls
now we've covered the rising crime rates
already the supply chain crisis
continues to make lives hell and then
there's this
uh los angeles and uh and uh um uh um
what am i doing here mr president
mr president there's two famous guys in
this audience here don't pay us
the
former general i keep calling in general
my
my
visit vaccines.com.gov
vaccines.com or text to
your text your zip code to
438829 and i know i guess it's two weeks
or a week i'm losing track of time so
where are we
that instills confidence but it raises
the question how can you be lost in
thought
when you have no thoughts
yeah we're in worse shape than stelter
after the holidays
did you know his astrological sign is
eggnog
so what are our leaders focusing on
right now terrible cold-blooded
well the friday if on this last friday
the white house released a 42-page plan
to solve these very problems
i kid it's to promote gender equality
because that's the urgent problem and no
not just at home
but abroad yeah abroad
that's funny
a sexist would say
never mind the murder rate the open
border hyperinflation here at home
there's a hostess at the ihop and cutter
making three cents less than her male
counterpart
thankfully we've already been telling
the taliban to hire more women
but apparently this is to remedy an
unequal playing field one that has been
worsened by covid which is such bs the
smell of it should be seeping out of
your tv so you want to talk covid
inequality the global death rate for men
from covet is about 50 percent higher
than women
that statistic were reversed there would
be marches and they'd be the kind of
marches that the media would say don't
spread covet
but 50 that means for every 10 women
there were are 15 dead men who are men
who croak
in america 65 000 more men have died
than women i bet that's the first time
you heard that and probably the last
because unlike me gender equality only
goes one way
if you're a woman
who disagrees try registering for the
draft never mind industrial accidents
and fatalities the ravages of war the
obvious lifespan gaps men often get the
shorter stick in life but we aren't
complaining
women however need a national strategy
to fix something that does not rate
compared to the issues that both genders
face right now under joe it's like a
doctor giving a patient with diabetes a
treatment for his dandruff
but it's the same old shtick as they
ignore issues that affect all of us
crime economy education flatulence on
planes
cat
they chase the easy identity driven
stuff gender equity racial diversity
stuff that helps no one but the
diversity consultants it's easy to do
and like mayor pete you don't have to do
any work
telling the world we're all sexist and
bigots is free it's the only plan the
democrats have that actually does cost
nothing but in kamala harris you
remember her she's the crazy lady that
cackles like a halloween witch in a
haunted house
so
they both they both wrote a letter
together
she held the pen
claiming
that rates of gender-based violence have
risen significantly really is that so
well maybe it's so because all violence
has risen significantly see they only
admit that the violence has gone up if
they can cherry-pick the victims but
gender-based violence went up along with
all kinds of violence a rising tide of
blood lifts all corpses
but at least we've heard from kamala she
disappears more often than jesse waters
when the dinner bill comes
yeah he's cheap
meanwhile the turmoil we see crime the
overdoses the mental illnesses the
sexual assault in loudoun county they
pretend none of this exists but fake
problems they embrace why is that let's
ask our angry white male
[Music]
wow i had no idea men were in such
trouble we're graduating less earning
less money and dying at faster rates
i guess on the positive side now we have
a good excuse for all that heavy
drinking we're famous for
cheers guys
that makes sense
so as our leaders virtue signal and
solve nothing our country rambles down
an uncertain path like my my little pony
collection it's weird and a little scary
we have leaders who deny what we see
with our own eyes and if we don't join
their phantom crusades who are called
racist or sexist or worse trump
supporters they've expanded the meaning
of white supremacists so much that it
even includes black moderates and
they'll film you in the bathroom if you
disagree and not for the normal reasons
people get filmed in bathrooms
fact is we're in tough times but only
the only jobs democrats create are in
diversity and inclusion departments that
divide and exclude weird it would be
nice to stop them but they're all flying
to another global warming summit in
scotland
let's welcome tonight's guests
he's so conservative his kids names are
life liberty and loving american
conservative union chairman met sure
[Music]
you'll believe his comedy is subjective
once you've been subjected to his comedy
writer and comedian joe devito
she carves up pumpkins like their
ex-boyfriend fox news contributor cat
tim
and paul bunyan is dressing up as him
for halloween by massive sidekick and
the nwa world television champions
so kat you are still a woman right yes
okay so as a male talk show host talking
about this topic i read the regulations
and it says i should go to you first yes
so
are you obsessed with gender inequality
well no but you missed something yes
like you know
you know women live longer but they also
age faster like in the eyes of society
like as you know greg it is my birthday
week yesterday right it's my thank you
i was born okay it's my birthday week
and so i'm turning 33. a 33 year old you
know it's not the same as a man turning
33 like a 33 year old man is like a
young guy with his life ahead of him
turning 33 as a woman people are already
saying stuff to me like
you look great for your age
that's not a compliment it isn't no
because it's just saying you look a lot
less close to death than you actually
are
just tell me i look like it's a lot
nicer
so there there's worse things about
being a woman but like i don't like hate
men thank god for that
that's a low bar
matt welcome to the show um do you think
this is a distraction
on purpose or do they really believe
this is the relevant urgent matter that
they have to go after right now i give
up i don't know what they're thinking i
don't know you see all these basic
problems that people have yeah and you
know they've been really helping women
around the globe i think of all those
afghan women they've really been helped
out recently that was a real good one
and i guess they're going to create kind
of like an even playing field amongst
the genders which they don't even
believe in right by uh you know making
sure that men keep dying of covid by
keeping tony fauchy in charge of the
whole thing there you go yeah i didn't
by the way
i didn't even know those stats until i
like looked them up this morning and i
mean i thought it would be like okay
slightly like you know maybe there's a
three percent 50 globally that seems to
me joe like a pretty big story that
someone like you and a tasteful beard
would be interested in
yes well i think a lot of it is because
men don't complain about these things
and personally i'm trying to change that
by complaining constantly yes about
everything yeah yes yeah it's it's scary
to see that these this is the kind of
distraction i mean of course they're
creating a distraction from from the
buffoons i have in charge i mean look at
people didn't go to work for two months
he was home breastfeeding and no one
even noticed he was gone i know that's
true chest feeding yes i apologize well
and i look at that like that shows you
that he not only is he not up to the job
his job might not be that important
right i know if my super puts up a sign
that says back in five minutes the
entire apartment building collapses yes
he's got a he's a guy who knows how to
do things these are people who don't
know how to do anything and somehow
they're in charge it's it's really
really scary well it's scary because of
the 10 of the of the day that they're
supposed to be working even just working
10 is destructive so i'd just rather
have them do nothing but unfortunately
they're flying to scotland for climate
change they're sending so many people to
scotland it's amazing the numbers and i
don't know i said get out i mean to get
out of the united states i guess tyrus
where do you sit on this particular
issue
oh i still sit where the hell i want to
um
you know i'm glad that you brought this
stat up because
i'm
men we have to
start being more equal
no i'm serious because these deaths are
exactly the reason why the next time you
hear a sound downstairs honey your turn
you know like we have been
[Laughter]
men have been convinced who runs into
the fire to save the baby the guy
someone breaks in the house the guy
hey coveted out there uh but i really
want my ice cream who goes to get it the
guy
so of course we get killed more because
we get talked into stuff and then if we
question it they're like really i
thought you were a real man
and we fall for this all the time so i
would just like to say fellas let's
start sharing the wealth next time we
hear a loud noise in my house i'd be
like you're up dear
you know and the other thing in the
buddha judge's defense it takes about
two months to get a breast pump on a man
to get milk out it's a long process so
have some decorum and respect that's
true i think you owe in a him it's going
to take a while yes i think tires makes
a good point that's why there's no
female version of when people say man up
yeah no because they're too smart yeah
women are too smart let the big dummy do
it do anything yeah i don't do anything
i don't even clean i'm uh we're i feel
that we are in danger of turning this
into an encounter group right
no we've tried interventions with you it
doesn't work
that is true hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else